[Música]
con ella vamos a hablar de cómo va la
campaña para el plebiscito el próximo 4
de septiembre sobre la propuesta de la
nueva constitución chilena el país está
dividido entre quienes anhelan cambios
sociales y quienes desconfían de la
propuesta constitucional dos meses
tienen entonces los chilenos para así
conocer y debatir los 388 artículos que
contiene este borrador de la nueva
constitución antes y drogas urnas el
texto que marcaría el comienzo de
cambios fundamentales en el país escribe
a chile en su primer artículo como un
estado social además democrático así
como plurinacional y también
intercultural y ecológico saludamos
entonces a sandra ponce de léon abogada
magister en derecho público convención
en derecho constitucional por la
pontificia universidad católica de chile
sandra gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24
esta mañana le pregunto para dar
entonces un poco de contexto cómo va
esta campaña por el sí o por el no cómo
están las cosas de cara a este próximo
plebiscito el 4 de septiembre en chile
donde ustedes nos van a decir entonces
si se quedan con actual constitución o
si realmente hay cambios
muchas gracias por la invitación
bueno efectivamente como tú decías
tenemos un gran desafío el 4 de
septiembre de presentarnos a votar toda
la ciudadanía chilena en un voto
obligatorio
para este plebiscito específicamente y
bueno las opciones son como bien desear
todos o apruebo o rechazo y
efectivamente hay o se está dando una
polarización en esos dos ámbitos a la
sociedad está bastante dividida hoy día
a propósito del texto que nos entregó la
convención constitucional en julio
pasado y bueno como aparecen ahí las
imágenes hay bastante esfuerzo empeño
por ambos posturas lo cierto fuerte
comenzar a
captar el voto precisamente en los
indecisos eso es lo que está pasando el
día en el en el país sandra como en las
encuestas le pregunto cómo está el pulso
digamos en las calles lo último que
tengo entendido y lo que estaba pues
leyendo era que él no digamos está
ganando en este momento de esta campaña
le quiero preguntar si esta brecha ya se
ha cerrado o sigue ligeramente con
vendaje no
claro sigue con ligera ventaja en el
rechazo pero con acuerdo a los expertos
en encuestas no sólo dicen que esa esa
opción no se toque el día se ve un poco
apretada parecerá que va en aumento el
rechazo y esto un poco
creado por el ambiente que existe
respecto de
la desunión
que no nos traería está este texto
constitucional en cuanto como decías tú
se declara un estado plurinacional con
una serie de beneficios derechos no
cierto para los pueblos originarios que
no serían
compatibles con el derecho del resto de
la población chilena eso es lo que tiene
bastante preocupado a la población en
general y ocupados no ser para los
analistas
enfrentar este tema no es cierto ya sea
para aprobar o para rechazar eso es uno
de los aspectos fundamentales para
adoptar una de las dos posiciones sandra
también usted como especialista en
derecho constitucional
digamos que quiere decir que chile en su
primer artículo es un estado ecológico
multi multi cultural también
pluricultural qué quiere decir esto en
términos de constitución y digamos cómo
se podría comportar digamos el ejecutivo
del país si se adopta esta nueva carta
magna
bueno precisamente esos son principios
que se
enarbolan en esta propuesta y que
obviamente que tendrían que guiar todas
las políticas públicas que el estado
emprendiera pero no solamente eso sino
que también cada uno de los
participantes partícipes no es cierto en
el estado toda la población tendría que
asumir precisamente esos mismos
principios en cada una de las
actividades que desarrollen nada así que
son
principios básicos resueltos sobre los
cuales se tienen que desarrollar como
les decía las legislaciones posteriores
para poder ajustar ese texto
constitucional con esas nuevas
previsiones con los nuevos principios a
la realidad y en la armonización de las
conductas de las personas y también del
estado todo el tapón porvenir no es
cierto y es una tarea importante que va
a tener de aquí a varios años más el
legislador para estar todas las
instituciones todos los principios todas
las normas de conducta hacia esos
principios eso es lo que podría ser
porque nosotros no tenemos experiencia
anterior nosotros no es una cuestión
cultural ni histórica en chile- haberse
declarado un estado como plurinacional y
podríamos entender lo que es un estado
concierto ecológico en el sentido de que
las políticas como las negocia públicas
y también las reglas de conducta de los
particulares van a tener que estar
orientadas a hacer un estado no ciento
que se orienta precisamente en la
protección de la naturaleza incluso hay
un derecho de la naturaleza que se ha
declarado en la en el propio texto
constitucional y así ahí hay una serie
de normas en las que ese principio
permea sí
sí sí y sandra y como lo decía no es un
proceso fácil no es que digamos si gana
el siguiente este produce en ese próximo
4 de septiembre
4 de septiembre cuando ustedes los
chilenos tengan que ir a las urnas a
decidir no es que el día de mañana pues
ya todo se cambió y ya todo se rige en
la nueva constitución como lo es bien lo
decía es un proceso
un proceso de transformación social por
decirlo de alguna manera sandra
lamentablemente se me acaba el tiempo
para entonces despedirla esta mañana y
gracias por supuesto por estar con
nosotros